So I came across this
idea the other day,
I think it was Aristotle
who put it out there,
but it was this notion
that human beings
don't care about spectacle.
What they care about is
ecstatic understanding.
Understanding, comprehension.
In other words,
cognitive ecstasy
defined as an
exhilarating neuro storm
of intense
intellectual pleasure.
The book "The Ravenous
Brain" talks about this idea,
that consciousness is
obsessed with pattern.
Pattern is structure,
structure amidst
the chaos, a signal
in the noise.
And when we find patterns,
when we connect the dots,
we experience this cognitive
ecstasy, this exhilarating
neuro storm.
And we get children,
they're young,
they're learning all
the time, they're
creating new
synaptic connections.
They experience this cognitive
ecstasy, this curiosity.
This insatiable drive to
understand is on fire,
is fervor, is [? feral ?]
in little kids.
Imagine the first time
you look at a microscope.
You see that cosmos--
revealed for the first time--
of the microscopic.
When you look
through a telescope,
and you all of a sudden see
the cosmos of the macroscopic.
Perhaps the best line was
Ross Anderson's description
of the ontological awakening
provided by the Hubble Space
telescope's images
of the deep field.
He said, "Through the
sheer aesthetic force
of its discoveries,
the Hubble distilled
the complex abstractions
of astrophysics
into singular expressions
of color and light,"
vindicating Keats'
famous couplet,
"Beauty is truth, truth beauty."
The sad part, as Sir
Kenneth Robinson says,
is that we lose
this as we grow up.
Our educational
institutions are failing us,
they're not providing the
context for this curiosity
to explode, to continue
to emerge indefinitely.
Instead we slowly die.
And I think our goal
is to create media,
to create content,
to create spaces
that allow us to stay
curious, to stay alive,
to awaken the wonder
junkie in all of us,
to unleash the brave,
reckless gods within us all.
That is my goal.
That is why we make
[? Shots of All ?], that
is why I love the
TED conference, that
is why we're here, that
is what we live for.
Ahhhhh.
Moves me every day.